what's the nice juicy 1/2 or she so
juicy one no that's definitely not Irish
hey guys I'm out of sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen and I'm here with my
friend joy from joyous health hey guys
so we love st. Patty's Day totally it's
so good we're both Irish so we're legit
we're legit we also totally got that
along you're gonna be overdoing it on
the fun juice this holiday we want to
share some our favorite green recipes to
help you feel a little bit better
okay so joy what are you making so I'm
gonna make a green blender seemed so
solid between all the degree in this
holiday I'm gonna be making some avocado
fries with moon-goddess
dip whoo and regardless is here so yeah
this makes sense I'm sorry guys
you want to feel your best on this day
yeah let's get started so joy we're
gonna make these fun little baked
avocado fries fun and these are actually
totally clean free and vegan so I love
them for entertaining so I'm just point
to and bust into these bad boys scoop it
out you pout and I'm gonna get you to do
the rest of sharing don't mind totally
and all start on the crumb topping all
right so we're gonna make a nice little
crispy coating because we love our fries
have that nice crunch factor and you can
get that without actually deep-frying
so what I'm gonna do is pulse some of
this crispy rice cereal I have some oat
flour so I love both flour I do this the
same in my food processor as well I just
pulse a bunch of rolled oats and you can
get them gluten free as well so we've
got some flax seed here also great
source of fiber your healthy fats as
well and some water and we're making
what we call a flat plate so if you've
never made a flax egg before it's kind
of a crazy idea but basically I'm mixing
together some water and some flax and
you set it in the fridge for about 10
minutes and when you're done you have a
nice thick consistency that actually
holds things together the same way that
an egg would
it really is so I'm going to nail season
up my oat flour I have a little bit of
chili powder for a nice kick boom got
some cumin here and then some basic salt
and pepper so this is the fun part so
joy if you want to grab that baking
sheet yeah we get to assemble these and
this is where I always get super messy
and I know I always tell myself one hand
just to dry one hand this away never
really doesn't happen now I'm messy too
so don't worry all right
no judgments them so first into the oat
flour just to give it a nice something
to stick to
oh I'm totally gonna make these and then
it's the flax egg okay then no and then
into the crispy crowd of this alright
well we've finished these problems don't
they look so they look amazing I just
love the combo of like textures it's got
like the crunchiness and the creamy
buttery in her so good people are going
to love this we had a party all right so
I'm gonna pop these into the oven at 450
degrees for about 12 to 15 minutes just
until they get nice and going around the
outside okay so now we're gonna work on
the Green Goddess dip because YUM one
green thing is not enough we need
exactly the greens so we've got some
silken tofu here just gonna pop this in
a little bit of garlic because of course
that's always gonna flavor things nicely
I've got some chives here parsley basil
one of my favorites
does that Dijon Dijon you should also to
make such a difference in revelry is
such like a secret ingredient is and
some maple syrup because I give you a
little sweet tooth balance every out and
some beautiful lemon all right a little
bit of salt of course and we blitzie
bits all right so these are
wait to try one up there crispy and
crunchy okay so I can't eat soy do you
have a suggestion cuz I really want to
try this dish totally totally so you
could easily use any kind of yogurt okay
and if you don't want food dairy free
and vegan you could use a Greek yogurt
be great thank you a coconut yogurt okay
those are all erased every you've got on
awesome ideas alright alright ready yes
dip dip dip
that how green oh good I love the French
jolt green yeah everyone behind the
camera is like let me try those and this
is so much better than late-night
poutine on st. Patty's Day oh you're
gonna feel way better now way better
after these little fries healthy
delicious YUM
well joy thank you so much for joining
me today thanks for having me thank you
guys all for watching if you like this
video be sure to give it a thumbs up
give it the little avocado fries leave
me a comment below with what you're
gonna be making on st. Patty's Day I
want to know and of course subscribe to
the channel check out Joy's video for
her amazing green soup you've got to try
this stuff it is so good so nourishing
and I will see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen